Brent and Kaitlyn by the way so they
went to a Halloween themed after
California I thought maybe they they
relax they relaxed and slow down on the
swinging exactly they said that it had
energized their sex life so they went to
a Halloween swingin club I got to admit
I do like Kaitlyn's costume I have a
picture of it oh really
it's like basically a bra and panties
what she's supposed to be a swinger
she's supposed to be like it like
Brent's dressed up as a devil and she's
like the devil's assistant or I don't
know something but she's basically in a
panties and bras she looks damn good
fact I should have Steve nawicki to come
in and he he was the guy who went down
there to cover this and at one point
Caitlin's going down on a woman while
Brent's jerking off and and Steve it all
of a sudden occurred to him he goes
Jesus Christ I'm watching Brent jerk-off
that's right this is my coworker Steve
when was this this Halloween bash this
was on Saturday night this past Saturday
I guess oh okay
was it disturbing to you very disturbing
I've never seen anything like this
is it because sex almost gets reduced
down to like a cattle like function like
like just animals having sex it was yeah
it was just animalistic there was
nothing sexy about it it's everywhere
you look somebody's got their dick out
people are getting blown everywhere and
it's there's no romance no romance to it
it's strictly the act yes and it's weird
to see people walking around naked with
your dick out right yeah I mean in that
and you'll I mean you'll get into it but
the orgy room the upstairs were they
they had different rooms
there were orgy rooms private rooms
people [ __ ] in front of those rooms
is I have you ever seen anything like
this was a weird watch and Brent's wife
go down on a woman yeah and was weird
watching Brent jerking off yeah he did
it multiple people he was fluffing his
penis all night while I would talk to
him I'd be like what are you doing and
he goes trying to get hard man and I'm
like what do you got to be laying nice
and he's knocking his penis all the time
[Music]